Je suis avec mes bros, je suis avec ma team
Ici elle a pris Fatale je lui ai demandé de switcher tout de suite
Là on a Tracer
Là on a le... Oh!!! Chacal en mode guirlande *rires*
*musique*
Overwatch est le FPS créé par Blizard. C'est un jeu où des équipes de 6 joueurs s'affrontent, sur différents modes de jeu
Y'a au total 23 personnages qui viennent
chacun d'un pays différent
et surtout d'une époque differente
Y'a de la vraie rivalité y'en a qui s'aiment y'en a qui s'aiment pas donc c'est drôle et j'me suis dit y'a vraiment un truc à faire
Avec ce délire là
Et j'me suis dit : Eh ben on va les faire se clasher
Hey dis-moi, avec ton antenne tu captes bien?
Oooh !
Hey ta jambe c'est une barre de Pole dance pour Mimi Mathy ou quoi?
Je suis garée juste devant j'vais y aller (ironie)
Attention !! à tes ailes
tes ailes Putain de merde !
Hey Natoo elle a failli tuer 600 fois quelqu'un avec ses ailes
*Musique*
Voilà, tu vois, c'est parti !! On est partis pour le Make-Up de Chacal
Moi j'suis un petit peu le taré de la bande
2H de make-up, et on se retrouve tout de suite dans 2H
Avec une tronche légèrement différente je pense
*Musique*
Je suis très ravi de ce tournage là
Cyprien : Merci Man !
Squeezie : Il va devenir Squeezie 2014 !
*rires* Squeezie : On part là-dessus !
Je ressemble a mon père comme ça !
Squeezie : C'est vrai ?
( imitation ) Squeezie : Hey Bapt !
Cyprien : Quoi ? C'est moi ! C'est Bapt !
*rires*
On me met un tapis sur la tête
Je te vois plus
Bah oui ! Je vais adopter ce p'tit look
Ah c'est pas facile d'être un ange ( ironie )
J'ai ma p'tit pose et tous ^^
C'est un Dyson qui ne perd pas l'aspiration, il y a pas de sac ^^
*musique électro*
*rires*
Salut c'est McCree et je vais tourner mes scènes !
Hé y'a Tracer là-bas
Putain, j'me crois trop dans mon rôle
J'ai vraiment l'impression de jouer à Overwatch et je rencontre mes potos d'Overwatch
Squeezie : ça va ou quoi vieux ? J'te fais la bise
Julien : Ohlala c'est beau *rires*
Squeezie : T'es stylé de ouf !
*Rires de tous *
*Voix off Squeezie * On s'est tous changés ! On était comme des gamins
à l'idée de ressembler aux persos d'Overwatch
MAIS...Mais
J'vais pas vous mentir ça a quand même un peu démystifié les persos
le fait de mettre ces costumes là, dans le sens où
en fait y'a des contraintes de malades dont on avait même pas idée
*rires*
T'a vu la montée de Bastion ? ( ironie )
Perso qui galère le plus au monde
Squeezie : Bastion on t'a vu ! On a découvert ton secret
En fait sous Bastion, y'a un putain d'humain c'est ouf !
*musique*
Dans le clip,Tracer court à un moment très très vite, ok ?
C'est très stylé mais dans la vraie vie ça l'est un peu moins
Et tout ça dans le clip rend très bien donc
on peut vraiment remercier les gars aux effets spéciaux
parce qu'ils ont rendu le truc très épique
*Musique*
Donc mon personnage c'est Ange
Et je suis censée soigner les gens
Du coup par exemple si vous avez
Un mot de gorge
Eh bien j'ai une pastille Drill
A distribuer comme ca... Hop!
Et tu n'as plus mal à la gorge
En vrai elle est plus sexy dans le jeu
La meuf
MAIS CASSE-TOI! T'ES QUI TOI!?
C'est la premiere fois je crois que
Que Blizzard
Communique avec des youtubeurs
Dans le clip on a pas l'impression
Mais à aucun moment ils sont tous ensembles
C'est que à chaque fois des rustines de :
Alors attends on va tourner Cyprien de telle heure à telle heure
On va tourner Mika de telle heure à telle heure
Moi j'aimerais qu'on salut le taf de ces excellentes
Jeunes filles qui ont fait un cosplay magnifique
Avec des trucs de LED
C'est fait tout ça avec des papiers recyclés du commerce équitable *rires*
Qu'elles sont allées elles-même chercher en Ouvdeckistant *rires*
C'est quand meme euh... On a jamais vu ça dans... *rires*
Genre moi je suis quoi je suis le DJ donc il leur fallait si tu veux euh un.. un Daft Punk un peu
de..de Grenoble
un 38 zehr
Eh ben ils m'on trouvé moi
Et j'trouve que ça, ça marche plutôt bien j'sais pas ce que t'en penses
Je suis le king d'Overwatch et personne ne peut me test
Un poncho barriolé, les poches pleines de billets
On fait la..la tournée des Leclercs
Tous les Leclercs de notre région
Les Conforamas..
Y'a pas de problème il peut venir chez vous
chanter la chanson d'Overwatch
Allez on y va
C'est parti
Est-ce que vous en voulez plus ?
Allez c'est reparti pour un tour
Bonjour Natoo
Bonjour je vais vous apprendre à rapper
Tu te prends pour un Dalton avec tes bottes et ton Stetson ?
Mais laisse-moi te rappeler que ton nom ce n'est personne
Voilà merci
*applaudissements*
Demain il fera très humide dans l'air
Et je vous laisse sur un son euh excellent
C'est le nouveau tube qui vient de sortir
T'es qu'un joker de pacotille, une pâle copie du bouffon vert
Un bouffon...tout court, mais ferme-là à quoi tu sers ?
A l'écriture, PV Nova, Julfou et Valentin Maury
ont fait un travail absolument génial
et merci à eux parce qu'à la base il faut savoir que moi j'avais écrit moi-même
trois ou quatre couplets du truc et vu que je suis extrêmement mauvais en musique
et qu'en plus toutes les semaines je dois sortir quatre vidéos sur ma chaîne
ben ça me laissait très peu de temps pour faire quelque chose que je maîtrise..très peu
Et faut savoir que cette chanson a été écrite avec des chaussons et en buvant du thé
Comme bon nombre de rappeurs
Toutes les tisanes à base de thym
Et ça a terminé sur un petit Colombo
*batterie*
on a quand même passé un temps fou à écrire cette chanson
faut être honnête pour chaque perso on explorait le champ lexical
par exemple du feu pour Chacal, de la glace pour Mei
Et on cherchait des vannes en vrac
et on en a gardé qu'un tiers on va dire pour chacun
Et donc voilà
*Squeezie chante bas*
Les missiles.. Cuba.. Tu l'as eu celle-là ou pas ?
Parce qu'on parle d'histoire mon pote
OHHHHHHHH
Voilà
*Batterie*
C'est la première fois que j'étais sur un tournage avec autant d'autres copains, Youtubeurs
Ils auraient pu se dire ''Olala... Lucas qui sort de ses jeux vidéos et qui veut faire un clip... Starfoullah, je suis pas très chaud'' *rire*
Urr... Fin de tournage, enfin
Natoo et Squeezie : Faites du bruit *rire*
Cyprien : C'est chiant...
Cyprien : Un jour avec ces gens là *coupé par Natoo et Squeezie* Natoo et Squeezie : Faites du bruit *rire*
C'est compliqué de tourner avec des gens immatures *Squeezie et Natoo derrière "faites du bruit"*
Natoo et Squeezie : " tapes des mains, tapes des mains, tapes des mains" *rires*
Ils ont huit ans
*(Musique)*
J'suis hyper content du résultat, j'suis hyper content de..du tournage, de la chanson
Les gens qui ont créé le son ont été extra, les gens aux effets spéciaux ont été extra
Tout le monde a donné du sien, a donné de sa bonne volonté et a aporté son petit grain au truc
Donc merci à tous les potos qui ont rejoint le projet
Et puis merci à vous d'avoir regardé la vidéo
J'espère que ce gros gros projet vous a plu, et que qui sait,
il y en aura peut-être d'autres comme ça à l'avenir, on sait pas
À très vite, au revoir
C'est très sérieux comme ça
À bientôt, merci